Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I can’t believe I am saying this, but today we are
going to read human minds by using AI.
Yes, that’s right. That really happened.
So how do we read brains? Well here,
we are mainly interested in peaceful,
non-invasive method, and that is going to be
an fMRI. Functional magnetic resonance imaging,
this is where you go into a tube, are asked
to stay still, and your brain activity will
be read. We get a result that is something
like this. So what is this good for? Well,
these are cross-sectional views
of the brain, slices if you will,
and not only that, but blood flow within
the brain can also be highlighted.
This gives us an idea about what parts of the
brain are activated and when. So for instance,
we can show someone an image of a
familiar face and an unfamiliar one,
and see if there is a difference in the
brain activity, and what that difference is.
That sounds great. However, not so fast.
With these peaceful non-invasive techniques,
the readings are not as precise, and there is so
much more noise. And now, hold on to your papers,
because this paper did something that I did
not think humanity would ever be able to do.
So here is the mind reading experiment they
propose. Chuck some folks into an fMRI machine,
show them images, and then make a brain reading.
Now this brain reading would have to be converted
to an image, not just this noisy blood flow
information, which sounds almost impossible.
And it is almost impossible. A previous work
from just 5 years ago did something like that.
These images went in, and this came out. This
is a reconstruction of what scientists think
the brain saw. In terms of shapes, there is
perhaps some correlation between the two,
perhaps they are related, but I feel like I am
grasping for straws here. And then, four years
later, two really promising works appeared that
could reconstruct these images from the brain. An
incredible scientific achievement, however,
still very blurry images. In this new work,
at the risk of simplifying a little, the
idea is to take these brain readings,
and plug them into the legendary text to image
AI system, Stable Diffusion. So what do we get
as a result? And now is the point where I fell
off the chair when reading this paper. Here are
the new results. Wow! Now we’re talking! These
are so much better. The readings show a strong
correlation of the real images that have been
shown to the subjects. And wait it gets better!
It also works for video! That means that we
can show these subjects all kinds of videos
and after the brain reading reconstruction,
we don’t get back exactly what was shown,
but the results are so much
higher quality than before.
Now, evaluating these results is a tough
matter, there are fundamental questions,
for a perfect reconstruction, are these two
supposed to be the same? Good question. Also,
the fMRI machine and the reconstruction
algorithm both have their limits. And the
list goes on. A healthy dose of skepticism
is a hallmark of the Wise Scholar.
However, for now, we can compare the reconstructed
results to the ground truth through, one,
visual inspection. Or, two, through mathematical
ways of comparing images to each other. With both,
this new technique has been shown to be
so much better than the previous papers.
And as every good paper does, this one
also raises important new questions
too. For instance, does it work for a diverse
set of topics? It does. And what I really want
to know - how similar would these images be
for different people? What do you think? Well,
I am delighted to tell you that there was an
experiment for that too. Absolutely lovely.
It almost feels like we are living in
a science fiction world. My brain is
also bubbling with ideas. I wonder what
that would look like in a video form?
So, is this work perfect? The
answer is no. Not perfect. Not
even close. There are still lots of
limitations and many failure cases,
and we should all exercise a little critical
thinking for works like this. But once again,
the help of AI research makes the almost
impossible seem possible. What a time to be alive!
Now, note that this video came way later than
it could have. That is not great for views,
but that’s not what we are after. We wait until
the paper is sufficiently reviewed, the evidence
is thoroughly checked, and I only want to show it
to you then. That is the only thing that matters.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!